okay for people who are joining this
live stream
we are looking at some incremental
language development
as we head into version 12.2 of orphan
language
and first on our list today
is the world of wonderful world of
combinators and i think i have to run
this in a different version here
um
so okay go ahead yeah
the first thing is to look at the glyphs
and
so yes and these here are they
are they in the product are they not yet
here they're not yet in the product
which is why there's a screenshot
there right in the middle okay
these updates are not in correct
um can we simulate this what what is
that thing
do you know what that is is it
is it close to bullet or is it something
different
it's bigger than bullet so the see that
comparison there so it's basically uh
i think it's small circle filled in
which is apparently smaller than filled
small circle
correct okay my question is what's it
going to look like when it has
parentheses mixed in with it
okay because that's the case that we're
going to see a lot
and i just want to simulate that so
where i mean we've got
um why it was bullet that's probably
i know i know i know so what i've got to
do is i'm just thinking about how to do
it because
i guess if you take bullet and like you
know move it up one size and and
font size yeah yeah right but i have it
but so
um i just want to say construct
um
what am i doing here i'm doing i want to
say groupings
of random choice s k
comma five or something
no four let's say
comma f arrow two
okay so then this gives us okay let's do
that
then now i want to make f be this bullet
thing
how do i make that an infix bullet isn't
an infix
um no
okay so what i want to say is is some
infix
form or something is that right it's
just
infix of
uh i think percent
comma bullet is what you want
no how does i want to turn every f into
a bullet yes which i
think would be infix
of percent comma the string bullet
i don't understand that how does it know
to put that into the f's
no it's just going to that's going to
turn the top level list into that
oh um yeah what i want to do is
take this and then i want to say this
thing slash dot
f of x blank y blank
goes to infix
of actually i don't need to say i just
need to say x blank
blank blank like that um
x colon this
i think goes to infix of that
comma bullet
right okay and then i want to do this
okay so i want to say ggg
that is ggg
slash dot that oh no what's happening
oh god no i i i want to how do i do that
i want to do
what i want to say is map
gosh this is remarkably hard to do map
hash slashed it
into this onto gg steven i have a
locally built front end with
the font so if you want to just dictate
to me and i share
okay why don't you just i'll just put
this in the chat and you can run this
okay
except i except instead of f i want
application there presumably right
um should i show your screen
okay so we have that guy
and now we change this to
psychotype why
is apple did i misspell this
or uh or oh does my kernel not have
application
this uh no but it has to have
application
so how can it not
why don't you go all right i'll i'll
stop sharing and if i get this working
i'll
i'll let you know okay but but that's
what we have to do to test this is we
have to get something with parentheses
in it
because um
look come on somebody help help me out
here we can do it with this
i want to map it
there we go there we go
that is it okay comments from
combinatory
aficionados there's too much white space
other than that i actually like this
better than the larger one
in the in the proposal i'm just using
the bullet well so how do we reduce the
white space do you think there's a way
to do that or
um
i mean that seems i
don't think there's that much whites i
wonder if that's because of the
well the insects greetings simulated
that's a simulated white space reduction
and i agree it looks a bit better
right except i'm not sure how much of
that white space is real and how much of
it is just
the the sort of the i know the infix ray
yes
right so that's what has to be checked
now now the question is if we made that
bullet slightly bigger
um by saying here you know
style i don't know what we need to say
here
let's say 12 point or something
let's say style 15 point
is that making it bigger is it not
making any difference
i'm very confused okay if you want me to
share i can show it to you all right
there we go there we go it would work
i i rebuilt my kernel and now i have
have it working
okay okay fine okay we'll look at in
just a second let's just see this
because i think we've got a good
simulation here
i can't really tell the difference
between those two sizes
i mean in um but this looks pretty
decent i think
roman what do you think in terms of yes
yes i agree and i mean
the designers will certainly tweak the
size to
the spacing correctly but but this looks
decent yes
attire let's see your screen okay
okay uh i don't know what happened to
all my s's
yeah those are well who cares but i mean
but yeah i mean i think it looks good
except maybe with the parentheses well
yeah but i think that it's
they're too big those dots are too big
we should go down in size
to more like more like the size we have
here that's just what the screen capture
is yeah
yeah over here this is fine and that's
the right spacing for it
and uh i think it'll be fine
could you just i could you go to is that
is that your natural size for that
window
no that's that's uh 200 this is 100
oh yeah i think the dots are too big i
think we want to go to the smaller dots
and i think we're good
okay okay all right you can unshare
thank you
okay um okay
next stop what about two-way room do you
also want the two-way rule to be
uh longer i'm good with that i think
that's fine
okay okay okay thanks okay wait a minute
are you are you off because
are you what are we doing with these
what are those things are they
are they the are they the bold of our
usual font or what are they
yes and and they're they're template
boxes so we can customize them however
we want
okay and in traditional form are they
they're serifed but often
often aren't they rendered sans
sans-serif bold sans-serif
that would be a question for not me i
mean
that's a combinator question yes well i
mean
what i know is that what we tweaked is
that
they are upright and not italic that's
as far as
as i could find the consensus but about
the font
i really don't know i mean if everything
else if the variables
are serif then these should probably
also be
well except that they're often rendered
sans serif i mean in in um
um just out of curiosity let's go to the
the master um let's look at
mr sean finkel himself um
well here they're both
here they seem to be italic and the
regular font
okay so yeah sean finkel
what survived for later on i mean
right i mean let me look i have a book
here
modern combinatory combinator book
um yeah well what they're doing is sans
serif bold
this is the um hindley and selden book
and we should do this just do the same i
think so i think that's the standard
sans serif bold so i don't know whether
we have a standard sans font that we
pick for that
guys i'd have to research that i don't
know off the top maybe ahead
maybe andy knows
andy the one that ships with mathematica
is
serif sans-serif yeah no no
what you're asking what i'm asking is
if we're going to use a bold sans-serif
font in traditional form
for these characters what should we use
right i mean what what is the style
specification that we should give
to get a to get a sans-serif
you know it's got what we need
do you understand the question i i guess
i don't the
just using the the normal bold sans
serif
is does not he does not he doesn't
you know this is a question for john let
me let me no no no no no no no i'm i'm
asking this
i'm asking what do i do to make this
sans serif do i say
font family if i give a font family it's
a specific
album the al nile font family you know
that's not the right thing what is that
generic
way of specifying sans serif you
understand what i'm saying
um that is you put source sans serif
or source no no no no
i'm talking about okay that is a
platform specific thing
right i'm asking is there a generic way
to specify sans independent of the
particular font on a particular platform
oh sorry yes that's what i was doing
sorry um no not that i know of
that's possibly something we should have
right which is why i said this is a
question for john
okay all right fine that's correct
okay all right so this is the
these are the named combinators that we
have is that correct
and they have predefined definitions
somewhere or not well there are no
definitions
i mean they have entries in the
axiomatic theory
but i mean what what's there to define
you cannot just blindly
reduce them right so no i mean the
question is whether we have a combinator
evaluate which basically just does
no no that wasn't that i believe that
was intended for the function repository
yes i mean what what our what my
understanding was that
we put the minimum required for proper
support
of the notation and the application into
12.2
and we have function repository for the
algorithms for now
and then we'll have something more
complete all right okay so
i mean my question is okay so this is
for mano
who's writing some of these function
repository things you should support
both lowercase s lowercase k and these
combinator s combinator k
things okay
okay i'm not sure what i'm going to use
in my my post about this stuff yet
i mean i would like to use these but i'm
not completely sure
i i need to get used to them um
and also it depends on when when version
12.2
ships relative to that and so on um
okay so there's one question that we
haven't talked
about is whether we should support some
short input forms for these because they
are kind of
kind of long to type yeah they are
yeah well they're not that long right
they're co and then
autocomplete well but there are too many
for the auto completion they
i mean by the way in the auto complete
ranking you should put
ski first right and will you specify
auto complete ranking
yeah we can do that but i i i agree the
escape sequences will be good so that
the input is
is short so that we can alright well
then let's say
escape you know lowercase c capital s
i don't think we're going to use that
for anybody anything else
right okay all right onward
okay so here we have now a discussion on
what axiomatic
theory and find the question of proof
should do and the discussion
is that and this is for jonathan to
comment
it seems that the general case requires
an extension
so that the theory is high order but
that makes the computations
very slow because we need the uh
non purely equational case
right right so that that is a problem
and that's not really one that can be
resolved right
um so they my find combinator proof
function has some optimizations that
uh gets around that issue but the the
basic issue is that um
i think stephen and i were discussing
this yesterday so there are
various subtleties that occur when you
attempt to make combinatory logic into
an algebraic theory
and one of them is that unlike in all if
you just do it naively
unlike in all other algebraic theories
there is a distinction between
intentional and extensional equality um
and so
so uh yeah if for exactly this reason
what you what you need to do
is if you want to be able to support
proving over both cases which is what i
think you do
you do need an additional essentially an
extensional um
equality axiom uh which i guess is what
you're doing here
um it is possible to optimize but but
ultimately that
we do need something like that so this
is the additional axioms
correct
gosh so it has an actual implication
function in there right
and i think that that's the problem that
it's that implication that
that it it's not easily cannot be
supported in in pure equational case
right i mean first order theorem proving
with fine equation or proof is is
significantly slower than equation
author improving
right is that many
many of the of the interesting theorems
can be solved already in the
questionable case so perhaps
here we should have just two collections
of combinator actions
i i agree but we should make it clear
that one of them is proving extensional
and one of them is proving intentional
equality
okay tell me a practical reason why one
cares
what do you mean well no what's the
theorem that you can't prove in one
go ahead you don't want to prove
theorems that are wrong that's the
practical reason
okay but but what type of theorem okay
so
again back to okay so i agree with you
we're going to need two sets of
combinator axioms
but what is an example of a theorem that
you can prove
if i removed all these equality axioms
here
okay so so i mean obviously the the the
trivial textbook example i mean
the one that's in all the textbooks is
sk and i right
so that would be an example what do you
mean s of s
yes go down to the examples you will see
it
okay it's right there so skk
and i are uh extensionally equal but not
intentionally equal
because basically you have to add a leg
to the thing to make it to show the
equality is that right
sort of yeah i mean the the point is
that they're not in this in the strict
deduct
okay if you compute the strict deductive
closure of the complementary axioms as
an abstract rewriting system
sk equals i is not a theorem in that in
that deductive closure
but it's still the case that
extensionally xk of x
equals i of x for all x
i understand in other words the thing
doesn't evaluate unless you put another
tentacle you know unless you unless you
add that argument to it
right right yeah and and the general
reason why that happens is because
i mean the thing we discussed yesterday
the fact that there isn't basically
there isn't a notion of lambda binding
so so you yeah you have a fixed number
of things that you eat
um i don't know how to read this dane i
think on our live stream says
uh those axioms look ugly sean finkel
will be disappointed looking at those
variables
yeah there's something to that it is a
bit disappointing that variable less
a variable le saxium system has to have
variables in it
i how does one do that there must be a
way of doing combinatory reduction
that mentions no variables
yes there is that's the nominal logic i
was telling you about yesterday
see the problem with jonathan is you
always have to tell me about things at
least three times for me to actually
understand them
yeah i didn't understand the nominal
logic thing what is the idea so the idea
is
the nominal logic um okay so there's
it's actually
i forget when when our logic programming
meeting is meant to be but this might
relate to
stuff we discussed there there are some
systems there's like
there's a theorem improving system
called alpha lean tap
that's based on this alpha logic where
basically you take
um you take first order logic and then
you mod out by
alpha equivalence right okay which is
this variable naming
thing right so so in in theorem in the
theorem proving well in the mathematical
logic literature these are called
grounded terms or grounded expressions
like ones that uh that don't contain any
free variables
you're just reasoning purely over the
syntactical structure
sorry what are they what are they called
grounded terms or grounded formulas
okay grounded formulas have no free
variables you're saying
right so so in effect when you yeah
when you do fear improving over nominal
object you're you're proving over the
set of grounded formulas
okay um and so what so the
the and in the comment and that becomes
relevant in the combinatory logic case
because the intentional
proving the proving of intentional
equality is a proof of combinatory
combination expressions as considered as
grounded formulas whereas the
extensional equality is the proving of
them as considered
full you know algebraic qualities
so is there an axiom system where you
just look at a whole skk
blah blah blah thing and you just do
substitution on that
of course but that's that's the
intentional that's only going to show
you intentional quality
unless you give it okay so intentional
equality
is the pure um you know pure
sk etc um
without i mean so basically what the
main point you're making is that s
s of k of k by the way we're hearing
some typing there
s of k of k of x if i say
if i if i say s k
um
sk fixed point evolve
i don't have it evaluated here um let's
see i
pull this up hold on one second
um
um
let's see okay here we go
okay so you're saying this thing here so
these are my
fixed point things by the way question
for roman which you might know
is if i'm doing leftmost outermost is
this the right way to guarantee to get
left most out of most ordering
is to say first to the sort by the
position
yeah i would have to look at this some
more
but uh i clearly need this at some point
in the language
what well these these reduction
strategies you don't have to do things
like this
right but um right okay in any case
sk fixed point evolve of this gives that
dandy okay so now just applying
the combinator nothing's going to happen
to skk
right because what you're saying is for
all x
skk of x equals i of x
right right right and so in an in an
algebra in a universal algebraic
structure
intentional and external equality are
the same which is how theorem proving
works
the trick with the tricky thing with
lambda calculus and with commentary
logic in particular is that they're not
equivalent
for this okay in what sense okay so hold
on hold on
the reason they're not equivalent is
because they're essentially a rules that
don't apply
it's not something where you can do
right there's no algebraic substitution
that you can do
it's just sorry the rule doesn't apply
right
right and so this is uh again i think as
we
we i may have mentioned yesterday that
when you do the naive translation from
um of lambda calculus or combinatory
logic into an algebraic theory
the one key axiom of the lambda calculus
which is this xy
rule doesn't hold yeah yeah that's
basically the extension out that's the
um
external the extensional uh axiom
essentially
the external equality and
the reason the reason you get that
subtlety essentially is because you
don't have lambda binding
in in combinators right but so here
there are things we can prove
that don't have to have variables
hanging out so we should say
um
what should we call them combinator
algebraic axioms and just combinator
axioms or what
or combinator nominal axioms
would that make sense if we call them
combinator nominal axioms
and those are the ones that just have
the s and k stuff in them
and combinator equational axis
does that make any sense jonathan others
jonathan can you comment
hello so
something i'm confused about is that the
sk equal i
can be proved with a simpler
case right i think it needs these things
doesn't it
jonathan are you still there no i mean
roman has the the the example there what
he calls the proof
sk equal one so yeah but
i mean these are the cases where you
stick in the variables and then you just
do naive reduction
exactly but if it works it's great but
if you stumble upon the
fixed one combinator then it usually
doesn't work
you've got something with an x here so
we know it works with an x
the question is where skk on its own
works
right now is jonathan still here or did
jonathan leave sorry sorry
my audio dropped but um i'm back now
okay fine
what what's okay so my suggestion is
that something like
that these would get called combinated
nominal axioms these get called
combinator equational axioms
is that stupid uh
[Music]
that's not stupid
i think yep yep that looks okay then the
names
these are a little bit unequational i
mean because these are these are two-way
i don't think it should be too it should
be two-way rule not left-right arrow
shouldn't it
because two-way rule has a fighting
chance of being usable
for something else left-right arrow is
purely syntactic
right and it has a nicer escape form
etcetera
right also rather than because they're
not strictly equational because they are
first order
propositions should we call them
intentional and extensional
or do you think we should stick with
nominal and equations i think
i will never be able to remember which
one is intentional which ones are
extensional
okay and i can't remember even right now
which one is but
but is it the case okay so the simpler
axioms
could not prove this if i look left off
oh it's if i if i left off the x here
and i just said equals i here yes then
we should be able to prove that right
uh yes but but only with ones that prove
only with axioms that take extensional
equality into account
okay but isn't that what this does
but then you shouldn't use an equals
right
i see so this would be left right arrow
whereas i mean here's is a trivial
example of something that is
intentionally true
which one is intentional which one is
extensional
i can't remember which which one is
which again
so so when we use equal jonathan which
one it is
sorry so if something keeps happening
with my audio um sorry so so extensional
is the one that's
you know where you're where you're
introducing arguments from outside
intentional is where you're just proving
things over the structure
okay
but what's the relation of that with
with having the additional x's
so the the additional x's is the
intentional case
but but we still have the exit now
you're confused
hopeless okay um
both of those those lists have the
additional access
and they can prove different things
right but but the x's in the
in the pure in the simple combinator
axioms
those x's are just
you know that in some sense you can
think of them as being like syntactical
x's they're just saying
anything anything including a variable
or a combinator could appear here
whereas the x's in some of the x's and
the full combinator axioms are acting as
variables not as combinators
i know that that distinction doesn't
really exist but yeah it's even more
complicated that's a typed
version of this but i thought the
problem here is that we want to use
application an application in the end
has to apply
to something so you need this additional
x
is it is isn't that the case no the
whole point is that skk
is equal to i in some abstract sense
it's like saying these two functions are
equal without saying
functions are equal you know
with specific argument this that and the
other
okay why isn't this working
well i think i think it's just slow it's
what we were discussing before but if
you try this
so slow what's that no no i understand
the other way of doing it will work just
fine
but the other way of doing it has an
equal sign here is that really a
justified equal sign
and why are these things not equal signs
up here
jonathan still with us uh yes so i mean
i i
i didn't produce this accidentization
but i would assume that not equal signs
because you need
when when doing theorem proving over
first order logic
the equal sign gets used in the
equationalization so your first order
axioms can't contain equal signs
the the the prover mixed
sorry please i
basically jonathan gave us a list of
extra axioms that need to be added for
application and so part of that was
using a formal equal instead of um you
know the built-in one
basically we find equational proof
doesn't yet support mixtures
of first order and equational logic if
you want to do that you have to define
your own sort of equality predicate
it either does pure equation or pure
first order not a kind of hybrid
is that a permanent thing or is that a
temporary thing
uh it's a temporary thing in the sense
that i can fix it
but it will take effort boy
this is complicated i mean unfortunately
what we're dealing with here
is you know different shaped pegs so to
speak
boys it's difficult
look i i think we're not going to have a
perfect solution for this version
and the only questions we got you know
yes i mean i would
strongly suggest that we at least
support
those what are you called simple ones
because that's the kind of
simple examples that everyone does
understanding that they are not good
enough
for everything i i agree so actually i
think in the spirit of what roman was
saying before about having minimal
functionality in system and then
exposing everything else to the function
repository
so because the new version of find
combinator proof does support both
extensional and intentional proving with
options what we could do is just include
simple combinator axioms
in axiomatic theory and then document it
to say find equational proof
by default only does um extensional
proving
uh but then have uh find a combinator
proof in the function repository that
can do both
so in other words we support this form
here yeah exactly
so maybe we support that form and call
it something like combinator
nominal axioms or something
is that even correct or do we just call
it combinator axioms
i think we can just call them combinator
axioms okay
all right fine i mean it it's just
the the the problem is not okay this is
what i'm going to say what i'm about to
say is going to sound a little bit
obscure
the problem is not what whether the
things you're describing are combinators
or not
it's it's what the meaning of the equal
sign is
right yeah i understand um but as long
as we make it clear in the documentation
that that equal sign
means intentional equality then we're
okay
sorry it means extensional equality
i love it we're just totally confused
here um
damn there's dane is commenting on a
live stream so it's not really find
equational proof but find extensional
proof
that's a good point i mean because in
ordinary logic
the axiom of extensionality says that
you i mean in effect this is what
univalence is right univalence is saying
the univalence axiom is saying you can
convert between equality and
extensionality
in other words that if things are you
know things are algebraically equal then
you can treat them as being identical
what we're encountering here is the
well-known fact of combinatory logic
that it's not a univalent theory
what do you mean by that
so in uh so the univalence axiom extends
this notion of propositional
extensionality to
type theory right so it says that if i
um
essentially it's telling me that if if
two types are
sort of equal then i can treat them as
being identical yep
um and you know sort of constructive
theories based on homophobia type theory
and so on all obey the univalence axiom
combinatory logic if you just if you
naively axiomatize it
is not a univalent theory precisely for
this reason
because essentially algebraic equality
doesn't imply
um well algebraic equality and
structural equality are not the same
thing
what the heck is algebraic equality in
the combinator
well that that's the extensional case i
see where you've added enough variables
to saturate the thing
and so then it can do its thing whereas
if you don't give it enough variables
it can't necessarily decide that answer
so skkx because it's saturated you can
write a you know you can write a
multiplication table
with x s k s and k be it with the
the application operator being your
binary operation s and k
being constants and x being quantified
variable but with just
skk you can't write that multiplication
table
there's no sort of algebraic way of
reasoning about that you have to do it
structurally
right right
did you by the way do you know if
there's a finite model
for for you know for application
in the case where um
uh uh you know and then
for combinators well does anybody know
that there's there's a model
uh there's a this thing called well it's
due to a guy called plotkin
uh which is a finite model for the
lambda calculus which you can
sort of trivially convert to a finite
model for combinators
what does it actually look like anybody
know
i mean and um
um i just wondered whether the
i mean i've just never seen it's
explicit form
roman have you ever seen this explicit
form no i was very surprised
to learn that there should be a finite
model so that's not something i've ever
encountered
interesting well mr plotkin has papers
about
am uh wow
it's kind of interesting um did you find
his graph model
i found his um
uh
uh his thing about chemical systems
he's on to the same um he's on to the
same same schtick as we are
um yeah realizing the calculus of
communicating systems is related to
biochemical events
good for him where is
inf.ed dot act dot uk
who knows that's that's the edinburgh
university informatics department
oh okay as opposed to infirmary
okay okay okay
that must be what's what this is
fascinating um
okay okay so now what what are these
other things here so this is
um i think this is just another example
in preparation for your presentation
i was i'm collecting examples because
i'm probably supposed to write the first
draft of the the web pages for these
things
okay and so the other one this one is a
kind of larger and ugly one but just
want to show
uh this is a this this this does
combinator reduction and it detects
cycles and it stops
if it doesn't it goes too much or
there's too many
things so so i take combinator
expressions
apply some variables and see which ones
end up as ground terms
what is the ground term one that no
longer contains s and k
so it just contains the variable that
you stick in so here i generate all s
and k
expressions with up to four literals and
then i see which ones we use and so
you'll find all the
expressions that are equal to i
so you find s k k s k s further down
but also of course longer ones
right i mean you can also do reductions
that don't have the x at the end
yes but then i mean that that would be a
different search criteria
then i could then the only probability
most meaningful stop would be
when it no longer changes
right right right right so here so here
i only we turn those cases
where all the assets in case are gone
but that's a simple change
yes
okay
well looks reasonable enough all right
let's look at this non-binary
application
i think this is completely misguided and
wrong
well let's see so the idea here is
to allow application to take from
one or more arguments to simplify inputs
because in the same way that you may
want to
write uh right but you don't uh we don't
allow rule of a b
c as a shorthand for a goes to b
goes to c we allow it for composition
no well composition is flat it's not a
it's not a binary operator
either it's an up binary operator or
it's not
well composition here of this right
oops yeah so so composition is not a
good president here
it would be more like compose compose
did i think i have a comment at the very
end
uh we gave up on compose
and compose also didn't have an operator
yes but look i
either it's a either it's a binary
operator or it's not
if it's if it's if it's not a binary
operator then i don't know why we've
invented it and if it is a binary
operator then it doesn't magically turn
itself
into uh some other form
no it's the other way around i mean if
you look at if you want to
input a long list of left associative
terms like
a apply to b c d and so on
then it's very easy to enter it uh
without these parentheses but if you
want to actually say
convert a list of these into an
application then you would have to do
the
the grouping at the left associativity
by yourself and so
what this does if application has more
than two arguments it will automatically
turn itself into the binary form so it's
a merely
it's merely makes entry of expressions
simpler no how does it make entry of
expressions
easier you do f escapes
ap escape g escape
ap whatever you say list of a comma b
comma c
comma d and then you say apply
application to list
right it's more a programmatic thing of
course we have the operator as you say
for the input right for the interaction
otherwise you have to fold it in right
otherwise what you're doing is saying
fold exactly application onto that list
is that the right way around is that is
that a correct direction of folding
i think it's not i think it's very easy
i think it has to be fold right
no this is fold left yeah that's but it
is
left associated that is correct
so you just say fold the application
onto that list
yeah right quick yes okay i think we
should not
make application have a have a more than
binary form
okay but i think we should document the
fact that you unfold like that yeah i
mean
that's actually a good example for the
documentation yes obviously
yes
absolutely not that will just get blow
up any other use of application
right yes i think we really agree on
that one i mean it was
it was more an exercise of trying to
find the correct limiting case but uh
nobody will ever it will never happen in
the wild right there will never be
an application with no arguments
occurring naturally so
that's cool the fact you can say
application arrow construct and it turns
into that form
and construct goes to application is
that second thing you give there
right yes and that is unfortunately not
possible
because construct is not not really an
operator once it's there right
but i think it's it's nice enough that
you can use the ad sign at the
future filled circle on the right hand
side right and and these look like
fantastic properties and relations
examples for the rough page
yes of course yes that's why i came up
with them
right all right well this looks good so
is that good for 12.2
i think so i'm good good very good very
good
so we probably need a short docs meeting
at some point for the
web pages yes i'm happy to do that and
um i mean i'm currently you know
actively working on doing stuff with
combinators so that will hopefully shake
down any further issues with this
um i must say these things are so
bizarre just so bizarre
it's just like complete alien
set of concepts particularly for that
time i mean i'm just
you know anyway very surprising look i
don't think we're going to get to this
um
uh this major um
uh function repository thing
so i think we should we should wrap up
here and uh people following live
streams we actually have another one in
30 minutes about biosequences
um and i'll be there so i'll see you in
half an hour
oh you're gonna be there oh nice what
are you doing with biosequences
that makes me suspicious well well a
i've been trying to train these
scientific
computing people how to write proper
documentation but
i was involved because it's touching all
of the
strings manipulation function yeah yeah
yeah yeah
right okay look forward to seeing the
thank you all very much